- It's nice to see you.
- Hi everyone.
Oh wow.
- Have you all met?
Have you met Jamie before?
- No.
- No, this is my first time.
- No, Andrew Garfield's
one of my best friends,
we've worked together obviously there.
- Beautiful, I love that.
What a great guy, right?
- Yeah, he's the best.
- I heard that you went
out for the first season
of "American Idol", I didn't know that.
- Okay. Yes.
Not the first season-
- If you don't know that,
that was the season I was on it.
- No, sure I know, yeah.
- It wasn't the first season?
It wasn't the first season, it
was a couple of years later,
I'm not gonna say how many.
But I did go out for it and I tried,
like I did the Cardinal no-no, which was,
I tried to sing Whitney.
- Oh dear.
- I know.
- That's not a no-no.
- It's kind of a no-no.
- It's so hard.
- I tried to sing, "Run to You" and-
- You chose a big one, okay.
- I did, I did and I was so
nervous that when you go the
♪ Tell me what does it mean ♪
I went "Tell me, what does it mean?"
(audience laugh)
I spoke it.
- Wait, wait,
you did spoken word during
a Whitney Houston song?
(all laughing)
- You (indistinct) Whitney
Huston ever, wait what?
- I was 16.
- Oh my gosh.
- I was so nervous
but I was such a big fan.
- I love that you broke out
in spoken word.
- I did,
I did, and "American Idol" was just like,
I was like, "Oh wow."
- What did they do?
- They said, "Stop.
What was that?"
- Oh my gosh.
- And I was like, "Mm-hmm?"
Like I tried to play it off.
- Play it off.
- Like it was meant to happen,
- Was this planned?
- but it wasn't.
And they were like, "Do
you have another song?"
And I tried another
song and they were like,
"We think you're really cool,
maybe you should like be
on Disney Channel or act."
And I said, (smacks lips) "Okay."
- Okay.
(all laugh)
Loud and clear.
- Yeah and I was like,
"Maybe I'll try that."